-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-, Grammy-,
Tony- and Academy Award-winning
actress, singer and producer,
and the host of
"The Jennifer Hudson Show,"
which airs every weekday.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Jennifer Hudson,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hello. Welcome back.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-So happy you're here.
-Thank you.
I'm happy to be here.
-I think we're still
technically within the window
where I can talk
about Halloween costumes.
Do you agree?
-Yeah, a little bit.
-I mostly just want to talk
about you dressed up
like Missy Elliott
on your show
from the famous
"The Rain" video, right?
-Yes, I did.
-That's Missy. And you...
There was no -- I mean,
no shortcuts here.
[ Laughter ]
-No, we go all the way.
-You went all the way.
This is not some last-minute
"I'm going to be Missy Elliott
going to a Halloween party."
Like, throwing a Hefty bag on
or something.
-No.
-You just went the whole look.
-The whole look. Yes, I did.
-And she saw it.
-Yes, she did.
-And she liked it.
-She loved it.
-And she wrote, "You merked dat.
Whooty whoo.
You won. I love you."
-That meant something good.
-That's something good.
-It did.
It came from Missy.
-I'll tell you this.
I'm starting to come
to the conclusion that no one's
ever going to tell me
I merked anything.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know. If you dress --
-You're never too late to merk.
We've talked
about artists that inspired you.
Like Aretha last time
you were here.
But Missy was someone
who inspired you
when you were younger.
-Oh, my God, yes.
I mean, Missy is a legend.
-She is a legend.
-So I had to sneak it in there,
you know, like,
pay homage to her
with my Halloween costume.
So I really thought I was her
in the moment.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-I bet she's a very fun person
to think you are for a moment.
[ Laughter ]
-She is a fun person,
that's for sure.
And somebody, you know,
to pay homage to.
-It's really -- I mean,
it is a nice thing
that I think happens where
all of a sudden you realize,
like someone, you know,
you listened to when you were
younger is now a legend.
You know, you were
like someone you were aware of
and your parents weren't.
-Right.
-And then all of a sudden
you're like,
"Oh, and now they are just
a legend."
-Yes. And my kid wasn't aware
because he came with me
to work that day
when we -- I was in my Missyness
and he was like, "Who is that?"
He's like, "Oh, Mama, you ain't
going to be able to do that."
But I did it
and I pulled it off.
-I can't believe you --
-You see my Missy skills, kid?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can't believe your son
doesn't think you can do it.
-No. You know how kids are.
They don't think you can do
anything.
-Now, one thing you've done
since the last time you're here,
you were about to start
your talk show,
and now you're
in your second season.
Six Emmy nominations,
including best talk show.
-How am I doing? Thank you.
-You're a natural.
-Thank you.
-You were saying
one of the interesting --
We were talking backstage that
now
that you actually have
your own talk show,
you realize when you're a guest
on a talk show
that everybody who in the past
just seemed
like they were running around,
they all serve a purpose.
-Yes. You know,
now I get to understand.
Yeah. Why all the people
running around,
what they doing,
who's talking to me,
what am I supposed to do
when I come out here,
you know, the whole field
because it's different now
being on the other side
as the host.
And then it's weird again,
though,
but cool being the guest.
[ Laughter ]
I'm still trying
to make sense out of it.
-Yeah. Did you -- Was there
a part of hosting a show
that you were most worried
about before you kicked it off?
-You know what?
Speaking publicly, it's like
one of my biggest fears.
-Oh.
-So to take it on and like,
"Oh, you want me to talk
to a whole audience?"
And the first, like --
when we first started the show,
we would go like in for prep,
and if I was singing,
then I would do a rehearsal
with the band
and then go and perform.
If I was acting,
you work with an acting coach
and then you shoot a scene.
With the talk show life,
I'm like, "So we're just going
to like, sit and keep talking?"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh! That's what this is."
So that was surprising to me.
-It's so funny. I would say,
of every fear,
a fear of public speaking,
I would have guessed would be
a deal breaker for this job.
-You would think but, you know.
-It's like, "Well, I freeze up
if I see camera or lights,
but other than that,
I'd love to take the job."
You seem very natural.
And I mean, again,
one of the coolest things
about the job for me
is the people
you get to talk to
that you feel like maybe
you never would have
had a conversation
with otherwise.
Is there anybody where
you've been talking to them
and thinking, "I can't believe
I'm here right now"?
-Oh, my God. Several people.
Like, I fan out on a lot.
Like, I got to sit
with Smokey Robinson.
-That's a pretty good one.
-Talked to him.
And sometimes
I want to scream like,
"Oh, my God, this is Smokey
sitting right here."
But then I'd be like,
"Ooh, let me be Mrs. Host."
Like, whatever that is
to keep my composure.
-It is a funny thing
when you talk to legends
because you do want to do that.
You do want to scream it,
but you realize
they don't want to hear it
because they also -- he knows
he's Smokey Robinson, you know?
[ Laughter ]
He wasn't taking
advantage of the moment.
So the weirdest thing
is how you actually
have to, like, pump the brakes
a little bit
on your own fandom for people.
-Right.
To, you know,
be a host like yourself
and try to be polished
and, you know,
and not lose it and fan out.
But that's who you want.
You know?
-Just try to always move
like a video game character.
-Welcome to "The
Jennifer Hudson Show," you know.
-Yeah.
-How that's supposed to sound.
-It's nice when they put
your name in the title.
It makes it easier to remember.
Yeah, I love that.
I love that it's "Late Night
with Seth Meyers."
I'm like, "I'll forget a lot of
stuff, but that I can get."
Yeah. I have a lot more
to ask you.
Will you stick around?
-Yes, I will.
-We'll be right back
with more Jennifer after this.